bon début de semaine mesdames et
messieurs alors oui témoignage est
attendu au deuxième procès de guy
turcotte toujours accusé vous le savez
du meurtre de ses deux enfants
témoignage de d'isabelle gaston la mère
des enfants car innovation sans doute
comme moi je suis difficile déjà une
première fois une deuxième fois pour
madame gaston aujourd'hui week
témoignage très difficile dès la
première question l'a senti la couronne
lui a demandé comment elle avait
rencontré guy turcotte et s'est mise à
pleurer ils avaient des difficultés avec
les années donc 199 et aussi elle a
parlé des relations difficiles donc avec
monsieur turcotte un couple qui avait
des hauts et des bas beaucoup de chic 1
selon madame un gaston lui était
renfermé boudeur agressé par quoi il se
chicane est donc très souvent et elle
voulait que les problèmes se règlent en
2001 le couple a eu des difficultés
parce que madame gaston a trouvé des
photos pornographiques que guide dans
l'ordinateur
ils ont même rencontré un sexologue se
sont séparés sont revenus ensemble en
autre incidence jean adam gaston a
questionné une nouvelle fois monsieur
turcotte
donc c'était source de conflit il a
également appris qu'elle avait été
infidèle en 2008 il est parti de la
maison
fin janvier 2009 et isabelle gaston a
décidé de changer les serrures pour sa
protection
et c'est à ce moment là qui lui a dit tu
veux la guerre tu vas l'avoir il était
très agressif et elle se sentir menacée
elle partait pour un week-end en famille
à charlevoix ce moment là on parle du 20
février 2009
et donc c'était la dernière fois que lui
a parlé ensuite on souvient mais le 21
février
le fort de ses enfants à l'école les
enfants ont été retrouvés dans la maison
que louait monsieur turcotte à piedmont
donc le 21 février 2009
voilà et donc elle ne doit raconter à
nouveau toute cette histoire fait
meubles etc
son témoignage se poursuit demain
dernière oui le contre et ragga thouars
a commencé donc aujourd'hui est
effectivement devrait se terminer
et de même on sent effectivement c'est
très pénible pour elle c'est très
difficile
et là tu as terminé la couronne l'avait
dit d'ailleurs elle vous il voulait la
faire témoigner rapidement pour qu'elle
puisse en finir avec ce témoignage de
dompter pas facile une deuxième fois
pour madame me gaston mercier karine au
revoir